avec
des déguisements de la barbe à papa un
antidote contre la peur des moments
d'insouciance bienvenue pour ces enfants
victimes innocentes d'une guerre
insensée
[Musique]
c'est très important de rapporter des
sourires et de la joie dit maxime
steinhoff pour leur montrer qu'on peut
revivre et être heureux après l'horreur
et au chapitre de l'horreur la région de
borodianka n'a pas été épargné
c'est une des villes martyres de la
guerre théâtre de bombardements massifs
et d'exécutions sommaires aucun immeuble
ici n'est intacte et l'école ne fait pas
exception les soldats russes en ont fait
leur quartier général et l'ont laissé en
piètre état lorsqu'ils se sont retirés
nazar au pana cenco y remet les pieds
pour la première fois cet élève de 5e
année et rester terre et dans la cave
chez lui avec sa mère et sa grand mère
jusqu'au départ des soldats russes
le garçon de 10 ans a l'impression
aujourd'hui d'en avoir au moins deux de
plus hanté par des images et des sons
qui ne le quitte plus
le grondement des avions qui volent au
dessus de sa tête et le sifflement des
bombes il en a conservé un clignement
des yeux incontrôlable il se sait
traumatisé
j'ai encore peur quand j'entends des
explosions dit il je me met à trembler
[Musique]
ivanka et nastia ne cachent pas leur
impatience tout retourner à l'école même
si ce n'est que pour une brève visite
l'occasion de tourner la page sur un
chapitre sombre de leur jeune existence
même si les combats se sont éloignés
elles vivent encore dans la peur de voir
des soldats russes venir et leur temps
série sur les maisons leurs mères se
sentent désemparés
les fillettes sont encore effrayé distel
elle se met à pleurer ou courent se
réfugier à la cave dès qu'elle entend
des explosions
les enfants qui ont vécu de près les
horreurs de la guerre ici vont
clairement resté marqué pour la vie mais
peu importe la distance qui la sépare de
la ligne de francs c'est toute la genèse
du pays qui en gardera des séquelles et
hitch moustache je suis innocent
pourquoi les enfants ont-ils peur parce
qu'ils ont beaucoup d'imagination
dix sept psychologues et il imagine
toujours le pire comme la guerre
nucléaire et pour un enfant ajoute elle
il est aussi très traumatisant de
constater que ses parents ne sont pas en
mesure de le protéger
il est donc important que les enfants
retrouvent le plus rapidement possible
une vie normale mais le retour en classe
n'est pas pour demain beaucoup d'écoles
sont utilisés pour héberger des familles
déplacées celles qui n'ont pas été au
moins partiellement détruite comme celle
ci à macquarie
menu n'invite n'aurait pu être causé par
la colline 12.7 directrice est submergé
par la peine chaque fois qu'elle y met
les pieds
il ya de sûr votre chasse en hommage aux
zones où elles n'arrivent pas à
s'expliquer que l'on puisse ainsi s'en
prendre aux infrastructures civiles et
surtout aux enfants
ici jean françois bélanger radio canada
macquarie